when we look at
poor smallholder farmers across the
world
and particularly in my country india
we often think that what they need
is access to better tools
education
government support
markets and so on yes they need all that
but what they really need is
reliable and regular income to live with
dignity
a dependable income even if it is as
small as hundred dollars a month is
essential for them to stay out of
poverty
today their incomes are in and out of
poverty which is extremely painful
growing up in south india
i could not overlook
what poverty did to our farmers
i was about 17 year old when one day i
saw
a farmer
in my village sitting next to a farm
stream and eating something from the
ground
something did not seem right
i walked up to him
to see what was going on
i was shocked
to see him eat
mud
mud
brown soft mud from the stream
i was afraid he might die i yelled at
him what is a stupid mud eating business
he looked at me helplessly
and said i'm a farmer
my crops failed
my stomach doesn't know
that my pocket is empty
i walked away quite helplessly
that night
i shared this with my grandfather
he was a remarkable man well traveled he
was a part of indian freedom struggle
under the leadership of mahatma gandhi
unlike me he wasn't surprised at all
he knew of people who added rice starch
to mud to calm their hunger
and he told me something profound
if you see
a person walking on the road without a
footwear it is important to understand
the root cause
that the person doesn't have enough
money
to probably buy the footwear
i finished my college
started working with a big company but
that incident kept coming back to me
why are smallholder farmers in such
abject poverty what causes them to be so
desperate and why is it that even in
21st century india one farmer dies by
suicide every 51 minutes
my co-founders and i
spent about six months traveling
across india meeting hundreds of farmers
to listen to them it became clear
that climate risk
is a root cause
that causes
farming to be unpredictable
and unviable
farmers who make
reasonable money in one season can fail
miserably in the next
and
farmers who could grow crops earlier in
summers no longer get to grow crops in
summers
heat is so much more
the wells are drying up every year there
are new varieties of pests and diseases
farmers told us that
this is all because of god i said what
this is all because of god
god is the one who caused it god is the
only one who can solve it
god in that context i did not see as a
sign of hope i read it as a sign of
helplessness
we heard from the farmers
they knew the problem
but they could not
use these two words climate risk
so we got together a team of
engineers
scientists
designers from about six countries
to co-create a solution with our farmers
which is quite unconventional
and the solution is greenhouse in a box
we call it keti raksha it's a micro
greenhouse
it's a beautiful greenhouse which sits
in a small portion of the farmer's land
it's easy to build small structure
covered with netting on all sides which
cuts off heat prevents bugs and saves
water
we can't cool the entire planet in one
day
but we definitely can create climate for
a small portion of farmer's land to be
suitable for farming
from our first experiences of growing
vegetables staple vegetables like
tomatoes cabbage cucumbers
we observed that
greenhouses can increase yields up to
seven times
and
use 90 percent less water
all this was too good to be true farmers
knew that they could you know all these
things are so difficult to happen so
they couldn't believe it unless they
actually saw it in action
so to make this happen we had to have
the courage to reimagine
the agriculture reimagine the
agriculture for a small holder farmer
after all
this is not to grow tomatoes in an
industrial setting in alaska in winters
it is to grow tomatoes
for a small holder farmer buy a
smallholder farmer in sizzling hot
indian summers
so this greenhouse had to be small
enough to fit in a portion of their land
easy enough for them to use
and cheap enough for them to buy
one of the biggest challenges that we
could overcome in the process is
financing
thanks to our financing partners
today this greenhouse
is available with financing which is
fast enough and cheap enough
greenhouse costs about
thousand dollars
farmers pay a down payment of about 100
dollars and the rest is financed through
the loan
and this life-changing asset
adds
extra hundred dollars of profit on an
average to a household month on month
this is a good double of what they
otherwise make
marginal 5-10 percent increases in the
incomes of small holder farmers cannot
move the needle forward much because the
baseline is way too low
we need significant jump in the incomes
and that income has to be reliable and
dependable
to ensure that farmers succeed
we also provide quality seeds nutrition
training and advisory leveraging mobile
technology we rolled out the solution
after quite a few tests with farmers
about three years ago and we are
marching towards 2000 farmers in this
year and looking at hundred thousand
farmers over the next five years
hopefully hopefully every smallholder
farmer in my lifetime
[Applause]
the best technologies in agriculture can
reach the smallest of the farmers if we
do two things well
listen to the farmer with curiosity
empathy and compassion
and
keep smallholder farmers particularly
women farmers at the center of the
design
and build solutions
then we can co-create many solutions
like keti rakshak which bring dignity
hope and stability to the lives of the
farmers
in this big fight against climate change
we all have to remember that we should
take our small holder farmers along it
is our collective responsibility
india is a home for about 100 million
small holder farmers
i dream of a day where
small holder farmer becomes synonymous
with a happy farmer
and
being forced to eat mud
should never be a feature again anywhere
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]